Maybe you saw this story about a month ago. This couple was sailing across the Pacific Ocean on a boat with their two young daughters. And one of the kids was three and the other was just a baby, like a year old. And the baby got sick and they called in rescuers. Four Air National Guardsmen parachuted in. A Navy vessel traveled 2,000 miles to reach them.
也许大约一个月前你看到过这篇报道。这对夫妇带着两个年幼的女儿乘船横跨太平洋。其中一个孩子三岁，另一个还是个婴儿，大约一岁。婴儿病了，他们呼叫了救援。四名空中国民警卫队员空降至此。一艘海军舰艇航行了2000英里才到达他们身边。
And this got a lot of play, can I say kind of weirdly, in newspapers, online, on morning TV.
这件事在报纸、网络和晨间电视节目中引起了极大的关注，我甚至可以说，这种关注方式有点奇怪。
Emergency medics parachuting in to save a sick baby on board a sailboat adrift at sea. ABC's Martha Raddatz here with that story. And Martha, so many questions about what that family was doing out there in the first place.
紧急医务人员空降拯救海上漂流帆船上生病的婴儿。ABC的玛莎·拉达茨（Martha Raddatz）来报道这个故事。玛莎，人们有很多疑问，关于这个家庭当初为什么会去那种地方。
So many questions this morning George. This rescue was as harrowing as they come.
乔治，今早确实有太多的疑问。这次救援是极其惊心动魄的。
On Good Morning America, George Stephanopoulos and Martha Raddatz updated viewers on the rescue. But also it raised the question that seemed to animate a lot of the interest in the story. That question, were these bad parents?
在《早安美国》节目中，乔治·斯特凡诺普洛斯（George Stephanopoulos）和玛莎·拉达茨向观众更新了救援情况。但这同时也引出了一个似乎激发了大众对该故事浓厚兴趣的问题。那个问题是：他们是糟糕的父母吗？
--but their trip immediately sparking criticism on the family's Facebook page. One person calling them irresponsible parents. Another writing, how selfish to jeopardize the lives of their tiny and helpless children. The family's boat has now sunk, along with everything on it. But this was indeed a very costly rescue. Everybody is very happy the baby was saved. But I don't know about you guys, but when I have children by a swimming pool I'm nervous. Don't know how they did it.
——但他们的旅行立刻在家庭的Facebook主页上引发了批评。有人称他们是不负责任的父母。另一个人写道，为了让年幼无助的孩子身陷险境，这太自私了。这家的船现在已经沉没，上面的东西也全都没了。但这次救援确实代价高昂。大家都为婴儿获救感到高兴。但我不知道你们怎么想，反正当我的孩子在游泳池边时，我会很紧张。不知道他们是怎么做到的。
Yeah. I don't know how they could do it at all. OK Martha, thanks very much.
是的。我不知道他们怎么能做到。好吧玛莎，非常感谢。
The front page New York Times story on the family was headlined, quote, "Two tots, a Sailboat, and a Storm over Parenting," and quoted experienced sailors arguing pro and con weather was OK to take a baby to sea. People went online and they read the blogs that these parents were keeping of their voyage online. And what a surprise, this being the internet they found things to get angry at. Comments on the internet ranged from, why take a baby out to see when she's a baby? After all, she won't remember it. To a point a lot of people made, quote, "This family should be forced to pay for the rescue. Who in the hell takes two little kids on a voyage like this."
《纽约时报》头版关于这个家庭的报道标题是：“两个幼童、一艘帆船和一场育儿风波”，并引用了经验丰富的海员的观点，争论带婴儿出海天气是否合适。人们上网阅读了这些父母在网上记录航行的博客。令人惊讶的是，正如互联网的惯例，他们发现了一些让自己愤怒的地方。网上的评论五花八门，从“为什么要带婴儿出海？毕竟她又记不住”到很多人提出的观点：“这个家庭应该被迫支付救援费用。到底谁会带两个小孩进行这样的航行。”
So that is how the whole thing looked from dry land. But 1,200 miles out in the middle of the ocean in the cabin of a 36 foot boat, it looked pretty different. The parents, their names are Eric and Charlotte Kaufman, say that a whole bunch of things had gone wrong besides the sick baby. The boat was taking on water. Eric is an experienced sailor with a Coast Guard Master's License. It takes 360 days on the water to get that, and it means that he can captain a commercial vessel, which he has done.
这就是从旱地上看整件事的情况。但在距离陆地1200英里的大洋中央，在一艘36英尺长的小船船舱里，情况看起来完全不同。父母的名字叫埃里克（Eric）和夏洛特·考夫曼（Charlotte Kaufman），他们说除了婴儿生病外，还有一连串的事情出了问题。船在进水。埃里克是一位拥有海岸警卫队船长执照的资深海员。获得该执照需要360天的海上航行经验，这意味着他有资格担任商船船长，他也确实担任过。
And he says that when things started to get bad on his sailboat, he started thinking about this piece of gear they have on the boat. It looks like a fluorescent green Big Gulp cup with electronics inside and a little antenna that's sticks out. It's called an EPIRB. EPIRB stands for emergency position indicating radio beacon. And basically when all else fails you break a seal, you push a button, and this device transmits your coordinates to authorities who know that it means that you are in trouble and they need to send help. And on day 16 of the trip-- well here's Eric and then also Charlotte.
他说，当帆船上的情况开始恶化时，他开始考虑船上的这件装备。它看起来像一个带有电子元件和一根伸出天线的荧光绿色大杯子。它叫EPIRB。EPIRB代表紧急位置指示无线电信标。基本上，当所有其他方法都失效时，你撕开密封，按下一个按钮，这个设备就会把你的坐标传给当局，让他们知道这意味着你陷入了麻烦，需要派人救援。在旅行的第16天——嗯，这是埃里克，还有夏洛特。
I just looked over at the bulkhead and there's the EPIRB sitting up there staring back at me. And I ran through it in my head a few times, like have we done everything we reasonably can do? Is this real? Is this really happening? We're not sleep deprived. This is a real thing.
我只是看向舱壁，EPIRB就坐在那儿盯着我看。我在脑子里反复想了好几遍，我们是不是已经尽了我们能做的所有合理的努力？这是真的吗？这真的发生了吗？我们不是睡眠不足。这是真实发生的事情。
We did the math that we were going to lose the boat. I was  going to have to scuttle it. I mean, we were married and lived on our boat. We were engaged and lived on our boat for that. Both of our kids grew up on that boat. And we were in the middle of crossing an ocean going to the South Pacific. I mean, how idyllic can you get, right? They write songs about that stuff. And instead we were about to push this button that shifts that whole reality into a whole different reality, and a reality we didn't want.
我们算了一下，我们要失去这艘船了。我不得不把它凿沉。我的意思是，我们结婚后就住在船上。我们订婚后也住在船上。我们的两个孩子都是在那艘船上长大的。我们当时正在穿越大洋前往南太平洋。我的意思是，还有比这更田园诗般的生活吗，对吧？人们为这些事写歌。而现在，我们即将按下那个按钮，把整个现实推向一个完全不同的现实，一个我们并不想要的现实。
This eventually became national news, the fact that you called for help. Did you have any sense of, OK, so we push this button and now we're famous?
这最终成了全国新闻，关于你们呼叫救援这件事。你们有没有意识到，好吧，如果我们按下这个按钮，我们现在就出名了？
No. Never. We were we were completely thrown aback by that. We thought some of the sailing message boards are going to have a thread about this.
没有。从来没有。我们完全被震惊了。我们以为只会是一些航海留言板上会出现一个关于此事的帖子。
After all, they knew about other boats that had called for help, and it never seemed to land anybody on morning television, or get talked about on The View, or even make the paper. And as for bringing two small children with them, it literally didn't occur to them that that could be an issue for anybody because they knew lots of other families through sailing message boards that they were on with kids just as young as theirs.
毕竟，他们知道其他呼叫过救援的船只，从来没见谁上过晨间电视，或者在《观点》（The View）节目上被讨论，甚至没上过报纸。至于带着两个小孩同行，他们压根儿没觉得这对任何人来说是个问题，因为他们通过航海留言板认识了很多其他带着和他们孩子一样大的幼儿的家庭。
Oh yes. In fact three other boats did the Pacific crossing this year. The youngest baby was four months old. And in fact, our daughter was the oldest baby. The one-year-old, she was the oldest. The rest were all younger.
哦，是的。事实上，今年还有三艘船完成了太平洋横渡。最小的婴儿只有四个月大。事实上，我们的女儿是最大的婴儿。那个一岁的，她是最大的。其余的都更小。
We reached somebody from the American Boat and Yacht Council, which writes the safety guidelines for these kinds of boats, and he confirmed that there are in fact thousands of families living on boats, tooling around the world with children of all ages. And he said that what the Kaufmans did was not unusual at all. In fact, he said, however it may sound to people who do not sail, crossing an ocean on a sailboat is routine. He said it was on the adventurous side of routine, but it was routine.
我们联系了美国船艇和游艇委员会（American Boat and Yacht Council）的人，他们负责制定这类船只的安全指南，他证实实际上有成千上万的家庭居住在船上，带着各年龄段的孩子环游世界。他说考夫曼一家的做法一点也不罕见。事实上，他说，尽管这对不航海的人来说听起来可能很奇怪，但乘坐帆船横跨大洋是常规操作。他说这属于冒险型的常规操作，但确实是常规操作。
So when Eric and Charlotte Kaufman got to safety and realized the reaction their story was getting, they put out a statement on the internet. It said, quote, "For those who are more critical, we ask that you kindly await all the details." They thought that if people heard the whole story, everything that happened to them, their choices would seem reasonable. But they didn't say any more. They didn't say anything else. They gave no interviews explaining what really happened until today.
所以当埃里克和夏洛特·考夫曼到达安全地带，并意识到他们的故事所引发的反应时，他们在网上发表了一份声明。上面写道：“对于那些更具批判性的人，我们恳请你们耐心等待所有细节披露。”他们以为如果人们听到了完整的故事，了解了发生在他们身上的一切，他们的选择看起来就会合情合理。但他们没有再说更多。他们什么也没说。直到今天之前，他们没有接受任何解释到底发生了什么的采访。
Today on our program we have them and their story. And we also have other stories of people calling for help. It turns out that when you call for help it can lead you to places that you never suspected that it possibly ever could. Including, by the way, we have former Wyoming Senator Alan Simpson stepping in to lend a hand about a matter that is not the kind of matter that one usually turns to the United States Senate for. Not actually the kind of thing that the Senate usually handles at all. Stay with us.
今天我们的节目请到了他们，讲述他们的故事。我们还有其他人呼叫救援的故事。事实证明，当你呼叫救援时，它可能会把你带到你从未怀疑过可能去的地方。顺便提一下，包括前怀俄明州参议员艾伦·辛普森（Alan Simpson）介入帮忙处理了一件事，这可不是那种通常会求助于美国参议院的事情。其实这根本不是参议院通常处理的那种事情。请继续收听。
Act One, When May Day Falls in April. OK. Some basic facts about Eric and Charlotte Kaufman. First off, OK, whatever impressions you have of people who own boats, they are not rich. The boat is their house. They have no other home. This is where their savings went.
第一幕，当五月天的求救信号在四月发出。好吧。关于埃里克和夏洛特·考夫曼的一些基本事实。首先，好吧，无论你对船主有什么印象，他们并不富有。这艘船就是他们的房子。他们没有别的家。这就是他们存款的去向。
Before they set sail last month, Eric made his living doing a computer job for a financial services company. Eric and Charlotte had been preparing for this trip seriously since 2010 when they started buying safety gear and did all the careful steps you do to make a ship as safe as possible, replace the rigging and chain plates, that kind of thing. The plan was they were going to travel to the Pacific Islands, make it to New Zealand before November, then live in New Zealand for a couple years, and then on to Micronesia and Indonesia, then who knows where.
在上个月起航之前，埃里克的工作是为一家金融服务公司做计算机工作。埃里克和夏洛特从2010年开始就一直在认真筹备这次旅行，当时他们开始购买安全装备，并采取了所有谨慎的步骤，尽可能让船只变得安全，更换索具和链板，诸如此类。计划是他们要前往太平洋岛屿，在11月之前到达新西兰，然后在新西兰生活几年，接着前往密克罗尼西亚和印度尼西亚，然后谁知道去哪儿。
When I asked Eric how long the trip was going to be, he didn't have an answer. Years for sure. The idea was they would head out and then just figured it out. Which made me especially interested in the moment that they decided to give all that up and call for help. What happened that made them abandon everything they had been hoping for and planning for for years and years?
当我问埃里克这次旅行要持续多久时，他没有答案。肯定要几年。想法是他们会出发，然后边走边看。这让我对他们决定放弃一切并呼叫救援的那个时刻特别感兴趣。究竟发生了什么，让他们放弃了多年来一直期待和计划的一切？
Well, Eric said that one of the big problems began the day before they called for help. Basically they sailed into a part of the ocean called the Intertropical Convergence Zone where they hit some nasty weather and waves. Not horrible Eric said. You'd expect this kind of thing on an ocean crossing. But they were getting rained on every 30 to 35 minutes with squalls, waves are going over the boat, covering the deck. And then-- here's the bad part-- they get broached, which is sailing language for a wave pushed their boat onto its side, just for a few seconds, and then it righted itself.
嗯，埃里克说最大的问题之一是在他们呼叫救援的前一天开始的。基本上，他们航行到了被称为“热带辐合带”的海域，在那里他们遇到了一些糟糕的天气和波浪。埃里克说并不恐怖。你本就会预料到在大洋横渡中会遇到这种事。但他们每30到35分钟就会经历一次阵雨和飑，浪打过船头，覆盖了甲板。然后——糟糕的部分来了——他们被“横推”了（broached），这是航海术语，指波浪把他们的船推到了侧面，只持续了几秒钟，然后船又恢复了平衡。
We got knocked over several times. And people have asked Eric, were you scared out there? And Eric always says, no, I wasn't scared. But I was in the cabin with the girls, and one time our oldest was going to the bathroom by herself-- because she's three, she's almost four, and she want's to do everything by herself-- and when that wave hit it's the scariest sound.
我们被撞翻了好几次。人们问埃里克，你在外面怕吗？埃里克总是说，不，我不怕。但我当时和女孩们在舱内，有一次我们最大的女儿自己去上厕所——因为她三岁了，快四岁了，她想自己做所有事——当那个浪打过来时，那是极其可怕的声音。
Because it's just a big bang?
因为那只是一声巨响？
Yeah. It's this huge bang. It's like you were in a car accident. You're expecting to go up and see who just T-boned you. But it was a wave.
是的。那是一声巨大的巨响。就像你出了车祸一样。你期望往上看，看看是谁撞了你。但那只是一个浪。
And so you guys are downstairs in the cabin and Eric is upstairs driving the boat. Is he upstairs out on the deck when the boat gets turned on its side?
所以你们在下面的舱室里，埃里克在上面驾驶船只。当船被侧翻时，他在上面的甲板上吗？
Yes. He was definitely on the side decks. But he goes out there clipped in, and we all maintain the rule, one hand for you, one hand for the ship. So he's always holding on.
是的。他确实在侧甲板上。但他出去的时候是扣上安全扣的，我们都保持一个规则：一只手给自己，一只手给船。所以他总是紧紧抓着。
So he's clipped on with straps and stuff, so he can't just go into the water?
所以他用带子之类的东西扣住了，这样他就不会掉进水里？
Right. Yeah. I think the hardest part for people who don't sail to really imagine about this trip is that you're constantly in motion. You're burning calories just by sitting because your body is constantly fighting to keep you in an upright position. We could never stand still.
对。是的。我认为对于不航海的人来说，关于这次旅行最难想象的部分就是你时刻处于运动状态。仅仅是坐着你就在消耗热量，因为你的身体在不断地抗争以保持直立姿势。我们永远无法静止。
When I'm making food, I have to brace my feet at a really far angle, or I had to wear a belt, a galley belt, just to stay upright. We would have to-- our youngest daughter, she slept in a little chair, a little kid seat, strapped down in her bunk because, if we had just put her in her berth, her body would literally have been just rolling five inches. Rolling five inches. Rolling, because she was too little to lay spread eagle and brace herself at night to sleep.
当我在做饭时，我必须把脚架在一个非常大的角度，或者我必须系上一条腰带，一条厨房工作腰带，才能保持直立。我们不得不——我们的小女儿，她睡在一个小椅子里，一个童座，绑在她的铺位上，因为如果我们只是把她放在铺位上，她的身体真的会直接滚来滚去五英寸。滚五英寸。滚来滚去，因为她太小了，晚上睡觉时无法张开四肢支撑自己。
Now, to get broached by itself is not such a big deal. Eric says lots of boats get broached.
现在，仅仅是被横推本身并不是什么大不了的事。埃里克说很多船都会被横推。
Yeah. I mean, you want to minimize it as much as you possibly can. And you probably did something wrong, or you could have been more active on the helm, or something like that. But it's not like, oh, my gosh, this is horrible. No boat has ever experienced this. That's not the case. It's sailing across an ocean. It's what it is. If you don't want to take hits like that, don't go across an ocean.
是的。我的意思是，你会尽可能地减少这种情况。你可能做错了什么，或者你在舵上本可以更主动一点，或者类似的事情。但这不是说，哦，天哪，这太可怕了。没有任何船经历过这种情况。事实并非如此。这就是横跨大洋。就是这样。如果你不想遭受那样的冲击，就别横跨大洋。
The problem, he says, is that when their boat got knocked on to its side, it put the boom into the water. Now I didn't know what a boom was, and so he had to explain that to me. If you picture a triangular sail on a sailboat, there's the mast which runs vertically from the deck, sticks into the sky. And then the horizontal pole that runs along the bottom of the sail, parallel to the water, that's the boom. And when they got broached, the boom went into the water. And when the boat bounced back upright-- the boom is connected to the mast and the rigging, which is connected to the hull with wires and chain plates-- and with all that pressure on the boom--
他说，问题在于当他们的船被撞到侧面时，横杆（boom）进了水。我不知道什么是横杆，所以他不得不向我解释。如果你想象帆船上的三角形帆，有桅杆垂直于甲板，指向天空。然后沿着帆底部平行于水面的水平杆，那就是横杆。当他们被横推时，横杆进了水。当船反弹回直立状态时——横杆连接着桅杆和索具，索具又用钢丝和链板连接到船体——随着横杆上所有这些压力——
That basically yanked on enough stuff that it caused breaks in the hull in a couple different places, which-- I knew where a couple of them were. And then some of them actually just proceeded to get worse and worse. And then at that point we started having a lot of leaking at the hull deck joint on the starboard quarter. Sorry for turning into boat nerd on you, but that's-- I think we ended up maybe about taking on 60 or 70 gallons a day, which isn't really that bad if you think about how quick you can move the bucket if somebody put a gun to your head and said, move that water.
那基本上拉扯了足够多的东西，导致船体在几个不同的地方出现了裂缝，其中一些地方我知道在哪儿。然后有些实际上就开始变得越来越严重。然后在那一刻，我们开始在右舷四分之一处的船体甲板接缝处大量进水。抱歉对你变得这么“船极客”，但我认为我们最终可能每天进水60到70加仑，如果你想一下，如果有人拿枪指着你的头让你把水舀出去，你移动桶的速度有多快，这其实并不算太糟。
He had a big, heavy manual pump on board that pumped a gallon with each stroke. So 60 to 70 gallons took a few minutes. No biggie.
他船上有一个又大又沉的手动泵，每按一次能泵出一加仑。所以60到70加仑只需要几分钟。没什么大不了的。
Yeah. The boat's not going to sink at that point. We're not all going to die because we've got a bunch of water coming in. It's a pain in the ass, but it's not the end of the world. There you are. It was under control.
是的。船在那一点上不会沉。我们不会因为进了一些水就全部死掉。这很麻烦，但并不是世界末日。就这样。一切都在控制之中。
So that was one thing, but there was another. Their baby daughter Lyra was sick. Now, contrary to what you might have read or heard about this part of the story if you followed this story at all, the baby was not sick when they started their trip. She'd had salmonella poisoning before they set out on the trip, but they waited for her to get better. They delayed their trip. And they only went to sea after they got a clean bill of health from her doctor.
所以那是一件事，但还有另一件。他们的小女儿莱拉（Lyra）生病了。现在，和你如果关注过这个故事可能读到或听到关于这部分的内容相反，孩子开始旅行时并没有生病。在他们出发前她得过沙门氏菌中毒，但他们等她康复了。他们推迟了旅行。他们是在得到医生出具的健康证明后才出海的。
For the first week of the trip she was healthy. But then, seven days in, she got a rash. Here's Charlotte.
旅行的第一周她很健康。但七天后，她起了皮疹。这是夏洛特的说法。
Kids get rashes, so we didn't freak out. But then her ears started to smell like cheese. At first we thought it was because we weren't bathing enough. We were all pretty dirty. So we cleaned her ears up, and they still smelled like cheese. So now we've got two things going on. And then she started getting diarrhea. And then she started acting lethargic. And when your kid starts to act differently, that's when you need to really pay attention.
孩子起皮疹很正常，所以我们没惊慌。但后来她的耳朵开始闻起来像奶酪。起初我们以为是因为我们洗澡不够。我们大家都挺脏的。所以我们清理了她的耳朵，但它们仍然闻起来像奶酪。现在我们遇到了两件事。然后她开始腹泻。接着她开始变得萎靡不振。当你的孩子开始表现不同时，那就是你需要真正注意的时候。
So they got on the satellite phone and they called Lyra's doctor. And he said to give her amoxicillin, an antibiotic. Which they do for a couple days, and it doesn't work. The kid's still sick. And now they don't know how worried they should be.
所以他们拨通了卫星电话，呼叫了莱拉的医生。他说给她服用阿莫西林，一种抗生素。他们给喂了两天，但这没用。孩子还是病着。现在他们不知道应该有多担心。
With kids, within 24 hours you should see results with antibiotics. And there was no improvement.
对于孩子来说，24小时内应该就能看到抗生素的效果。但没有好转。
Now the two days that Lyra is taking antibiotics are the same two days that the boat enters those rough seas where they're getting broached and water starts to leak in. And so, on the morning of their 16th day at sea, Eric decides, as safety precaution, to advise the Coast Guard of what is happening, just in case things go south.
现在莱拉服用抗生素的那两天，也是船只进入波涛汹涌的海域，遭受横推并开始漏水的那两天。因此，在海上第16天的早晨，埃里克决定作为安全预防措施，通知海岸警卫队发生了什么，以防万一情况变糟。
We're just going to let them know, hey, this is the situation, this is our medical situation, this is who's on board, this is the sea state we're at right now, so that if this gets any worse, they have some context of what's actually happening.
我们只是要让他们知道，嘿，这就是情况，这就是我们的医疗状况，这是船上的人，这是我们现在的海况，以便如果情况变得更糟，他们对实际上发生了什么有具体的背景了解。
And he called them with our satellite phone and gave them that update.
他用卫星电话打给他们，并提供了那个更新。
--which, in the Maritime world, it's not the most common thing to do, but it's certainly smiled upon to do that.
——这在海事界，不是最常见的事情，但这样做绝对是受赞许的。
And they said, OK, we're going to talk to the doctor here. Leave your satellite phone on for a certain amount of time and we'll call you back. And when we hung up with them, the satellite phone never worked again after that call with the Coast Guard. We weren't able to reach anybody else. It just said SIM card error, SIM card error over, and over, and over.
他们说，好的，我们要和这边的医生谈谈。在一定时间内保持你的卫星电话开启，我们会回拨给你。当我们挂断电话后，卫星电话在那次与海岸警卫队的通话后再也没工作过。我们无法再联系任何人。它只是不断地显示SIM卡错误，SIM卡错误，一遍又一遍。
And I tried everything. I took the thing out, and cleaned it, and prayed to it, and begged it, and put it back in. And I tried dialing the emergency numbers, and then it was like, sorry, from where you are you can't dial the emergency number. And I'm like, this is so awesome.
我试了一切办法。我把它取出来，清理干净，向它祈祷，恳求它，又把它放回去。我尝试拨打紧急电话，结果显示，对不起，从你所在的位置无法拨打紧急号码。我说，这真是太棒了。
They found out later what happened. Apparently, a week after they'd headed out to sea, their satellite phone company changed the brand of SIM card that it used. And the company mailed new SIM cards to everybody who had a phone through the mail, the regular mail, even though people with satellite phones-- the whole point of a satellite phone-- is that you're not anywhere normal. Right? You're off far away on a mountain, or a desert, or anywhere that regular phones do not work.
他们后来发现发生了什么。显然，在他们出海一周后，他们的卫星电话公司更换了所使用的SIM卡品牌。公司通过邮件，普通邮件，给所有拥有该手机的人邮寄了新SIM卡，尽管拥有卫星电话的人——卫星电话的全部意义在于你并不在任何正常的地方。对吧？你在远离城市的深山上，或者是沙漠，或者任何常规电话无法工作的地方。
So they mailed us a new SIM card, and then they deactivated them a week after they mailed them. So there was just some guy in some office somewhere that was drinking his coffee, and at the exact same time I hung up the phone with the Coast Guard, he like, ba-dupe, pressed this little button, and then that's it. Game over.
所以他们邮寄给我们一张新SIM卡，然后在一周后就停用了它们。所以就是某个办公室里有个家伙正在喝咖啡，就在我挂断海岸警卫队电话的同时，他就像，“嘟”的一声，按下了这个小按钮，然后就是这样。游戏结束。
But have no fail, we have a long range radio. There's two different radios on the boat, and we use that. But that seawater that I was talking about coming down the starboard quarter, well, the battery compartment is under that stuff and so was the radio fittings. So all the radio, over the last few days now, was all getting bathed slowly but surely in a nice coating of seawater. And I get on the long range radio and I started issuing pan-pan distress calls, which is like the step under a Mayday, on the emergency--
但别担心，我们有一台远程无线电。船上有两台不同的无线电，我们用了那个。但我刚才说的从右舷四分之一处进来的海水，好吧，电池仓就在那些东西下面，无线电配件也是。所以所有的无线电，在这过去几天里，都慢慢地但肯定地被浸泡在了一层漂亮的海水中。我用远程无线电开始发布“Pan-pan”遇险呼叫，这就像是Mayday的下一级，在紧急频道上——
Pan-pan?
Pan-pan？
Pan-pan, yeah. Pan-pan, pan-pan, pan-pan. This is the sailing vessel Rebel Heart at position da-da-da-da-da. Yeah.
Pan-pan，是的。Pan-pan，Pan-pan，Pan-pan。这是帆船“反抗之心”（Rebel Heart）号，位置在……等等。是的。
OK.
好的。
So we started doing the pan-pans and didn't get anything back.
所以我们开始发Pan-pan，但没有得到任何回应。
Does that mean that the radio isn't working, or does that mean that no one is close enough to hear you?
这是否意味着无线电坏了，或者是否意味着没有人在足够近的地方听到你们？
I don't know.
我不知道。
I thought, how are we going to do this? I made him do the math. I said, how much longer do we have? if she is sick and she doesn't get better, will we be there in a week? And he did the math, and three weeks, and I thought, oh gosh, how are we going to do this?
我想，我们该怎么办？我让他算了一下。我说，我们还有多少时间？如果她生病了且没有好转，我们一周后能到吗？他算了算，要三周，我心想，哦天哪，我们该怎么办？
You wouldn't be there for three weeks. Wow.
你们三周内无法到达那里。哇。
Yeah.
是的。
Now, it's not just that they're three weeks from where they're going. Where they're going is incredibly rustic-- the Marquesas island chain in French Polynesia.
现在，不仅仅是他们离目的地还有三周的路程。他们要去的地方极其原始——法属波利尼西亚的马克萨斯群岛（Marquesas island chain）。
A beautiful place, but a place that is not notorious for its medical services. Right? Like they don't have a blood testing facility there. Right? The first place we were going to go to doesn't even accept-- they don't even use money.
一个美丽的地方，但并不是以医疗服务闻名的地方。对吧？他们那里连验血设备都没有。对吧？我们要去的第一个地方甚至不接受——他们甚至不使用货币。
So he and Charlotte sit in the boat's cabin and they talk. He remembers he had his logbook in his hand.
所以他和夏洛特坐在船舱里交谈。他记得他手里拿着航海日志。
So at that point you've got a boat that isn't horribly bad. But you've got a boat that has flooding that your automatic bilge pumps won't keep up with anymore. No one would go to sea on a boat like that. It's not good. It's not fatal. But it's not good. We have unknown, other structural damage that's causing water to come in, beyond what I've been able to see. Yeah.
所以在那一点上，你有一艘状况还不算太坏的船。但你有一艘自动舱底泵已经无法应付进水的船。没人会乘坐那样的船出海。这不好。但这还不是致命的。但并不好。我们还有未知的、其他的结构性损伤导致进水，超出了我能看到的范围。是的。
One of our solar panels was ripped off. Some of our electronics were starting to fail because the water was going into the battery compartment. Our satellite phone was out. So now if we needed any other kind of medical care at all-- if somebody bonked their head, anything-- my child had whatever medical stuff was going on with her. The symptoms are pretty clear and laid out as they are. And I don't see it getting any better.
我们的太阳能电池板之一被撕掉了。因为水进入了电池仓，我们的一些电子设备开始失效。我们的卫星电话坏了。所以现在如果我们还需要任何形式的医疗护理——如果有人撞了头，任何事情——我的孩子有她身上发生的那种医疗状况。症状非常清楚，就像表现出来的那样。而且我看不到它有任何好转。
When you lay it out this way, it seems like it wasn't actually a difficult decision. It seems like it was obvious what to do, like you didn't actually have to struggle. Do I have that right?
当你这样说出来时，看起来这其实不是一个艰难的决定。看起来要做什么很明显，就像你其实不必挣扎一样。我理解对了吗？
Yeah. It really took about 10 minutes once I realized-- I mean, really once you know that you have a person on board that is sick with an ailment that is not responding to the treatment that is provided to it, and you no longer have access to medical care, and you won't for weeks to go, and that that person is-- once you know that right there, what else would you do? I mean, what would you do? Would you just keep sailing for three weeks?
是的。一旦我意识到——我的意思是，真的，一旦你知道船上有个人生病了，所患的疾病对提供的治疗没有反应，而你又无法再获得医疗护理，而且未来几周都无法获得，那个人又是——一旦你清楚地知道了这一点，你还会做什么？我的意思是，你会怎么做？你会就这样继续航行三周吗？
Now, of course, if they take action, if they use the EPIRB-- remember the EPIRB is the emergency device that calls for help-- nobody is going to tow their boat to safety, they're boat which they had been living on, their boat that was their whole life. Nobody was going to pick them up, and save their daughter, and then return them to their boat later.
当然，如果他们采取行动，如果他们使用EPIRB——记得EPIRB是呼叫救援的紧急设备——没人会把他们的船拖到安全地带，他们一直居住的那艘船，他们一生的那艘船。没人会接走他们，救了他们的女儿，然后以后把船还给他们。
And at that point, he said we've got to use the EPIRB. And I had walked forward in the boat, which is a challenge. Forward is always the bumpiest part of the boat. And I was kind of feigning like I needed to go to the bathroom, but I was really just trying to walk away from the decision. And he just followed me forward and sat there talking and saying this is what we've got to do. And I'm standing there holding onto the boat, bumping up and down because I'm in the bumpiest part of the boat. And you know that if you hit the EPIRB, help will come. But when you hit it you also know that [VOICE BREAKS] your home is gone.
在那一点上，他说我们必须使用EPIRB。我走到船的前部，那是一个挑战。前部总是船上最颠簸的地方。我假装我需要去洗手间，但其实我只是想离开那个决定。他跟着我走到前面，坐在那儿说这就是我们必须做的。我站在那儿抓着船，上下颠簸，因为我正处在船最颠簸的部分。你知道如果你按下了EPIRB，救援就会到来。但当你按下它时，你也知道 [哽咽] 你的家没了。
Damn.
该死。
Yeah. [SNIFFLES]
是的。 [抽泣]
So that's the hard part. You're safe. Well, hopefully you'll be safe. But that's it.
所以这就是困难的部分。你是安全的。好吧，希望你会安全。但就这样了。
Logistically, I go, and take it, and strap it up to deck up on one of the handrails up on the foredeck So it has a little sticker that says, keep a clear view of the sky. And then it just sits there strobing, which is interesting because you wonder, is it actually doing anything or is it just strobing.
从后勤上讲，我去拿了它，把它绑在船头甲板上的护栏上。它有一个小贴纸，写着“保持天空视野开阔”。然后它就坐在那儿闪烁，这很有趣，因为你会想，它真的在起作用吗，还是只是在闪烁。
And then you wait. There's nothing, no magical sparkles that come out. There's nothing that says, we got it. We got your message. You just have to trust that somebody, somewhere, in front of a computer is getting this message and it's going to help coordinate getting you help.
然后你等待。没有什么神奇的火花冒出来。没有任何东西说，我们收到了。我们收到你的信息了。你只能相信某个地方、某台电脑前的人正在收到这条信息，并将协调为你提供帮助。
So that was in the morning of their 16th day at sea that they pushed the button on the EPIRB. It took until near sunset for anything to happen. First there was a burst of static on the radio, which they thought was dead, the radio. They hadn't heard anything from anybody on it in a week. It was a plane with rescuers saying they were on their way.
所以那是在他们海上第16天的早晨，他们按下了EPIRB上的按钮。直到日落时分才发生了一些事情。首先无线电中传来一阵静电噪声，他们以为那东西坏了，无线电。他们已经一周没在上面听到任何人的声音了。那是一架救援飞机的声音，说他们正在赶来。
And then this C130 just comes screeching out of the middle of nowhere and buzzes us-- it seems like maybe 100 feet, 200 feet off the deck-- really close, comes right on top of us. And then in my head, on the one hand you want to start singing the national anthem. Right? You're seriously like, dude, no corniness aside, this is awesome. I live in a country that can do this. This button I pressed caused this plane to show up. And then you start wondering, you're like, wait a second. It's a plane and we're on a boat, and we need to get out of here. How is that going to work?
然后这架C130运输机就从虚无中尖叫着冲出来，从我们头上掠过——看起来可能只有100英尺、200英尺离甲板——非常近，直接冲到我们上方。然后在我的脑子里，一方面你想要开始唱国歌。对吧？你真的会觉得，老兄，别说这很俗气，这太棒了。我生活在一个能做到这一点的国家。我按下的这个按钮导致了这架飞机的出现。然后你开始怀疑，你会想，等一下。这是一架飞机，我们在船上，我们需要离开这里。那要怎么运作？
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
What? You know. Sure enough, they throw smoke grenades out the back and out come-- they kick some gear out the back that comes out on a parachute. So then these four guys all jump out of the back with their parachute gear and they have a Zodiac, an inflatable boat with and outboard on the back. And they press some buttons and [ENGINE NOISE] this thing pops to life and they all hop in it. And then, long story short, they got close to us. We got close to them. And then we bring these guys on board and they just hop on the boat. And then one of the guys immediately went down and started working with Lyra.
什么？你知道。果不其然，他们从后面扔下了烟雾弹，然后——他们从后面踢出了一些装备，挂在降落伞上。然后这四个人都带着降落伞装备跳了出来，他们有一个Zodiac，一种带舷外机的充气艇。他们按下一些按钮 [引擎噪音] 这个东西启动了，他们都跳了进去。然后，长话短说，他们靠近了我们。我们靠近了他们。然后我们把这些人带上船，他们直接跳上了我们的船。然后其中一个人立刻走下去，开始照顾莱拉。
This is the baby.
这是那个婴儿。
Yeah. They're all very highly trained medical professionals. So one of the guys just immediately went to her.
是的。他们都是训练有素的专业医务人员。所以其中一个人立刻走向她。
The Pacific Ocean is so big that it took three days for a Navy vessel to get to them at full speed. The four guys stayed on the sailboat with the Kaufmans during that time with all their gear in the tiny, non-air conditioned cabin. Six adults and two kids in this small boat. Eric says everybody got to know everybody pretty well.
太平洋太大了，以至于一艘海军舰艇全速赶到他们身边花了三天时间。那四个人在那段时间里和考夫曼一家一起待在帆船上，带着他们所有的装备挤在狭小、没有空调的船舱里。六个成年人和两个孩子在这艘小船里。埃里克说每个人都很好地了解了彼此。
When they transferred off the boat to the USS Vandergrift, Charlotte had the kids say goodbye to their home, and she said goodbye herself. Eric cut some hoses inside the boat which flooded it with seawater and sank his own boat. He didn't watch it go down though.
当他们从那艘船转移到范德格里夫特号（USS Vandergrift）军舰上时，夏洛特让孩子们告别了他们的家，她自己也告别了。埃里克切断了船内的几根软管，导致船体灌满海水，沉没了他们自己的船。不过他没看着它沉下去。
It's been a month now. They never did figure out what exactly Lyra had that made her so sick. And she's still not completely recovered, but she's doing better. And Charlotte and Eric say they do not regret the decision they made.
已经过了一个月了。他们终究没查出莱拉到底得了什么病让她病得那么重。她仍然没有完全恢复，但正在好转。夏洛特和埃里克说他们不后悔自己做出的决定。
And I don't really need anybody to validate that. I know there's people out there who have their thoughts and their commentary about things, sending emails that me and my family should go drown. I couldn't really give a [BLEEP] less what a whole bunch of people think. I mean, we were where we were. We had the situation that we had, and here we are.
我真的不需要任何人来证实这一点。我知道外面有人有他们的想法和评论，发送电子邮件说我和我的家人应该去淹死。我根本不在乎一堆人怎么想。我的意思是，我们当时就在我们所处的位置。我们遇到了那样的情况，而我们现在就在这儿。
Alive.
活着。
Yeah. So I could flip it around the other way and say I'm a 35-year-old man who made his family homeless. If I'm feeling negative about it, I could look at it that way too.
是的。所以我可以反过来说，我是一个让家人无家可归的35岁男人。如果我对这件事感到消极，我也可以那样看。
Eric Kaufman. Coming up, Senators gone wild. Well, one Senator anyway. That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
埃里克·考夫曼。接下来，参议员失控了。好吧，至少有一位参议员是这样。一分钟后回来。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Call for Help. We've arrived at act two of our program. Act Two, Government Assistance.
这里是《这个美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天的节目，“呼叫救援”。我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，政府援助。
This next story is about what might be one of the strangest constituent requests of a politician ever. it's told to us by a fellow Public Radio reporter from WNYC, Anna Sale.
接下来的这个故事可能是政治家收到的最奇怪的选民请求之一。它由WNYC的公共广播电台记者安娜·塞勒（Anna Sale）告诉我们。
One day last fall my cellphone went dead at work. I left it to charge on a co-workers desk. When I picked it up a few hours later, there was this odd message.
去年秋天的一天，我的手机在工作中没电了。我把它放在同事的桌子上充电。几个小时后我取回它时，有一条奇怪的留言。
Ms. Anna Sale. This is Alan K. Simpson in the wilds of Wyoming. Former US Senator. I need to talk to you about an urgent matter. Nothing life threatening at all, I can assure you. But give me a call.
安娜·塞勒女士。我是怀俄明州荒野中的艾伦·K·辛普森（Alan K. Simpson）。前美国参议员。我需要和你谈谈一件紧急的事情。我可以保证，绝对不是危及生命的事。但请给我回个电话。
I was covering politics at the time, but there was no reason that former Republican Senator Alan Simpson should be calling me out of the blue, urgent or otherwise.
我当时在报道政治，但没有理由让前共和党参议员艾伦·辛普森无缘无故地给我打电话，无论是否紧急。
Anyway, give me a buzz at your convenience. As I say, I'm in Laramie right now, I was in San Francisco yesterday. Headed for Washington Saturday. And so there your are. OK. Thank you. Bye-bye.
总之，方便的时候给我打个电话。正如我所说，我现在在拉勒米（Laramie），昨天在旧金山。周六要去华盛顿。所以就是这样。好的。谢谢。再见。
I wanted to call him back immediately, but it was weird enough that I waited a few minutes until I was out of the office. It was the end of the day. I was on my way home walking up Sixth Avenue in Manhattan toward the subway. Senator Simpson, I said, this is Anna Sale. He sounded delighted to hear back from me. And then he started telling me why he called.
我本想立刻给他回电话，但这太奇怪了，我等了几分钟，直到我离开办公室。那是当天结束时。我在回家的路上，沿着曼哈顿的第六大道向地铁走去。参议员辛普森，我说，我是安娜·塞勒。他听起来很高兴我回电了。然后他开始告诉我他为什么打这个电话。
It didn't have anything to do with the national debt or anything else Al Simpson is known for in politics. He wanted to talk to me about my ex-boyfriend Arthur. In other words, Senator Alan Simpson, a total stranger, wanted to talk to me about my love life. I better explain.
这和国债或其他艾伦·辛普森在政界闻名的事情无关。他想和我谈谈我的前男友亚瑟（Arthur）。换句话说，参议员艾伦·辛普森，一个完全陌生的人，想和我谈谈我的私生活。我最好解释一下。
A month before, Arthur and I had broken up. We'd been mostly long distance for two years. He's an ecologist, and he was spending a lot of time in Wyoming doing field work. He was finally going to move to New York to be with me, but I had the feeling it wasn't for keeps. I asked him if we were going to buy a couch together and he dodged the question. So on the day I was going to sign a lease for our new apartment, we got on the phone and agreed to call it off. After we hung up, I backed out of the apartment and he had to deal with a half-packed U-haul in Wyoming.
一个月前，亚瑟和我分手了。我们有两年大部分时间是异地恋。他是生态学家，在怀俄明州做实地考察花了很多时间。他终于要搬到纽约和我在一起了，但我有一种感觉，他不会长期留下。我问他我们要不要一起买沙发，他回避了这个问题。所以在我准备签新公寓租约的那天，我们通了电话，同意取消。挂断电话后，我退掉了公寓，他不得不处理在怀俄明州装了一半的U-Haul搬家卡车。
No. It was not half packed. It was entirely packed, dammit.
不。那不是装了一半。它是完全装满了，该死。
This is Arthur. Our breakup was one of those classic, I love you, but this isn't going to work, breakups. Our version was, we're in our 30s. I'm a reporter in the city. You study wildlife in the wild. This doesn't have a future.
这是亚瑟。我们的分手是那种经典的“我爱你，但这行不通”式的分手。我们的版本是，我们都30多岁了。我是城里的记者。你研究荒野中的野生动物。这没有未来。
Arthur returned the U-haul. And just a tip if you're ever in this situation, he got all his money back when he mentioned the breakup. A few weeks went by, then Arthur texted and called. He'd changed his mind. He wanted to get back together. Arthur kept insisting he had a plan for how our lives really could fit together. I thought he was panicking about being alone.
亚瑟退了U-Haul卡车。如果你有朝一日遇到这种情况给个建议，他在提到分手时拿回了所有的钱。几周过去了，然后亚瑟发了短信打了电话。他改变主意了。他想复合。亚瑟坚持说他有一个计划，关于我们的生活如何能真正契合。我以为他只是在恐慌独自一人。
We were just in different places. You thought it was impossible for me to figure all that out, and I knew it was possible.
我们只是处在不同的地方。你认为我弄清楚所有这些是不可能的，但我知道那是可能的。
And you remember what you said to me?
你还记得你对我说了什么吗？
Well I basically said, this is not the way it's going to happen.
嗯，我基本上说了，这不是事情该有的样子。
No. It was even sadder. [CHUCKLES]
不。那更令人难过。 [轻笑]
Oh really?
哦真的吗？
You said, Anna, I know you're the only one for me. And I'm one of the only ones for you. I know that.
你说，安娜，我知道你是我的唯一。而我是你的唯一之一。我知道这点。
Oh, God. [CHUCKLES] Wow.
哦，天哪。 [轻笑] 哇。
It was so hard, so sad, but I just wasn't convinced. So I pushed ahead. I got busy with work. I even went on a few dates. I heard from friends that Arthur was a mess.
这太艰难，太令人难过，但我就是没被说服。所以我继续前进。我忙于工作。我甚至约会了几次。我从朋友那里听说亚瑟一团糟。
And at some point I was just sitting there and I just thought, well, I can't-- there's no argument that I can make. I've said everything I can say. So either she changes her mind or something else has to happen. Something funny has to happen. Things had just gotten too hard, and they had gotten too-- our story had just become too--
在某个时刻，我只是坐在那儿，我心想，好吧，我不能——我没有任何论据可以提出。我已经说了我能说的一切。所以要么她改变主意，要么必须发生别的事情。必须发生点有趣的事情。事情变得太难了，它们变得太——我们的故事已经变得太——
Heavy.
沉重。
Heavy. "Dear Senator Simpson, the love of my life, Ms. Anna Sale, lives in New York City. We've known each other for two years and three months. I love Wyoming and have indulged its pull a little too much. And so a month ago, Anna stopped believing I would ever close the distance to be with her, and she cut me loose. I don't blame her. I was being a fool and I took her for granted, but now I see, eyes wide open, my mistake."
沉重。“亲爱的辛普森参议员，我一生的挚爱，安娜·塞勒女士，住在纽约市。我们认识两年零三个月了。我热爱怀俄明州，并对其诱惑沉溺得过头了。所以一个月前，安娜不再相信我会缩短距离和她在一起，她把我甩了。我不怪她。我当时是个傻瓜，理所当然地对待她，但现在我睁大了眼睛，看到了我的错误。”
"Senator Simpson-- this is the one-- I poured my heart and soul into Wyoming for six years. I hope you will consider this as a favor for a man who's risked it all for that place. Perhaps"--
“辛普森参议员——重点来了——我为怀俄明州投入了六年的心血。希望你能把这看作是为一个为那个地方冒了一切风险的人帮个忙。也许”——
Arthur wanted Al Simpson to call me and invite me to a ball in Wyoming. All the Wyoming political royalty would be there-- Al Simpson, Dick Cheney. I'd known for months that Arthur was going to be a guest of honor at this ball. He was getting this big prize for Wildlife Research. I was supposed to be Arthur's plus one, until I told him I wasn't going anymore. That's when Arthur wrote to Al. And Al, and his wife Ann, got involved.
亚瑟想让艾伦·辛普森打电话给我，邀请我去怀俄明州参加一个舞会。所有的怀俄明州政治名流都会在那里——艾伦·辛普森，迪克·切尼（Dick Cheney）。我几个月前就知道亚瑟将是那个舞会的贵宾。他要获得野生动物研究方面的大奖。我本应该是亚瑟的舞伴，直到我告诉他我不去了。那就是亚瑟写信给艾伦的时候。艾伦和他的妻子安（Ann）参与进来了。
OK. When you first read that, what did you think?
好的。当你第一次读到那封信时，你想到什么？
I just thought it was the auditor, the agents. And I looked at it, put it away, and then Ann and I were in Denver. And I said, I got to do something with this thing. I think I'll just toss it. And Ann looked at it, and she said, worth a try.
我只是以为那是审计员、代理人之类的。我看了看，把它收起来，然后我和安在丹佛。我说，我得拿这东西做点什么。我想我还是把它扔了吧。安看了看它，她说，值得一试。
This is just the sweetest letter. And I thought, that would be a shame not to call.
这是一封极其甜蜜的信。我想，如果不打这个电话就太可惜了。
"With esteem and humility" he ends.
“怀着敬意和谦卑”，他结尾道。
He seemed very desperate.
他看起来非常绝望。
He was desperate, and some of that had rubbed off on Al. When he reached me on the phone that first time, I got a hard sell. You confessed he didn't know much about us. But he told me all couples have hard times. Then Ann got on the line and asked me, what have you got to lose? It was bizarre. But I was also moved. Arthur's Hail Mary was totally romantic. I told Arthur I'd go to the ball with him.
他是绝望的，而且其中的一些感染了艾伦。他第一次在电话里联系我时，我受到了强烈的推销。你承认他不了解我们太多。但他告诉我所有的夫妇都有困难时期。然后安接过了电话，问我，你有什么可失去的？这很古怪。但我也被感动了。亚瑟的最后一搏（Hail Mary）非常浪漫。我告诉亚瑟我会和他一起去舞会。
And that weekend in Wyoming was wonderful. The Simpsons were just as sweet and open as they seemed on the phone. They were easy to talk to. Arthur and I ended up telling them stories about how we'd met, and why we'd split up. They chimed in with their own. And then, a few weeks after the ball, Arthur and I got back together. He even moved in with me in New York. And strangely, we kept talking to Al and Ann Simpson.
那个在怀俄明州的周末非常美妙。辛普森夫妇就像在电话里那样甜蜜和开明。他们很容易交谈。亚瑟和我也最终告诉他们我们是如何相遇的，以及为什么分手。他们也分享了他们的故事。然后在舞会几周后，亚瑟和我复合了。他甚至搬来纽约和我同住。奇怪的是，我们继续和艾伦及安·辛普森保持联系。
After that first phone call, we talked a lot. They gave us advice. I needed it. I was still uncertain about the future. Because, look, I'm divorced, I'm in my 30s, I want to be a mother. I was so afraid of making the wrong choice again and losing time. And after things had been so strained with Arthur, it was a relief to listen to the Simpsons who'd been together 60 years but hadn't always felt like they were on solid ground either. They didn't always know what was going to happen together. Ann struggled in their marriage when their three kids were young. And before that, when they were dating Al was drinking a lot, and Ann worried that he was an alcoholic.
在那个电话之后，我们聊了很多。他们给了我们建议。我需要这些建议。我对未来仍然感到不确定。因为，看，我离过婚，30多岁，我想成为一名母亲。我非常害怕再次做出错误的选择并浪费时间。在和亚瑟的关系变得如此紧张之后，听听已经在一起60年但并不总觉得自己在稳固基础上的辛普森夫妇的话，是一种解脱。他们并不总是知道他们在一起会发生什么。当三个孩子还小的时候，安在婚姻中挣扎过。在那之前，他们约会时艾伦喝了很多酒，安担心他是个酒鬼。
They weren't just telling me these stories to get them off their chest. It did seem like they really wanted to help Arthur and me. It was surprisingly intimate and useful. So much so that I asked if I could come to their house in Cody, Wyoming and talk to them some more. They said, sure. They're like these elder statesman of relationships. They enjoy showing off what they've learned. Take this story about one big fight that started on a dance floor. Al and Ann were at some event.
他们告诉我不只是为了发泄。看起来他们确实想帮助亚瑟和我。这出奇地亲密且有用。以至于我问我是否可以去他们在怀俄明州科迪（Cody）的家中，再和他们多谈谈。他们说，当然。他们就像这些关系的资深政治家。他们喜欢炫耀他们所学到的东西。听听这个故事，关于一场始于舞池的大争吵。艾伦和安在一个活动上。
And she was dancing with a guy who I knew was a horny old toad. And I thought-- and she loves to dance. And so she's whirling around the floor and giggling and laughing.
她正在和一个我知道是个好色老癞蛤蟆的家伙跳舞。我想——她喜欢跳舞。所以她在那儿旋转、咯咯笑、大笑。
And so anyway, I got home and I said, I want to tell you something. I saw you snuggling up to that horny bastard there. And she said, look, I am not into this to play games. But I'm not going to be under a glass lid just because of your jealousy. And I love to dance. And I will do that. And I'm not going to jump in the sack with somebody, so I think you better get over it. Which really pissed me off.
总之，我回到家说，我想告诉你一件事。我看见你和那个好色的混蛋在那儿亲热。她说，看，我不是在玩游戏。但我不会仅仅因为你的嫉妒就被关在玻璃盖下。我喜欢跳舞。我会那样做。我不会和谁上床，所以我觉得你最好克服它。这真的激怒了我。
So I gave her a lecture-- it was a beautiful thing-- about life, and fealty, and love, and loyalty, and all the rest. I thought, she won't sleep a wink. And 10 minutes later, I look in, she [SNORES]. Absolutely dead, but asleep.
所以我给她上了一课——这是一件美妙的事情——关于生活、忠贞、爱、忠诚以及所有其余的事情。我想，她肯定睡不着觉了。10分钟后，我往里看，她 [打呼噜]。绝对死睡，睡着了。
Guilt free.
无罪恶感。
Guilt free. And me? I got boulders in my gut down here. I didn't sleep, but I did one important thing. I'd always loved Shakespeare. And I went in and read Othello that night-- took a long while-- how he killed the most beautiful person in his life, Desdemona, choked her, smothered her right in the bed, the marriage bed. I thought, Jesus, this is one sick son-of-a-bitch. This is not me. This is totally destructive and has nothing to do with her.
无罪恶感。而我？我这儿肠子里像坠着石头。我没睡，但我做了一件重要的事。我一直热爱莎士比亚。那天晚上我去读了《奥赛罗》（Othello）——花了好久——他是怎么杀死生命中最美丽的奥赛罗（Desdemona），掐死她，就在床上，婚姻之床。我想，天哪，这真是一个病态的狗娘养的。这不是我。这完全是破坏性的，和她毫无关系。
The Simpsons say they learned to get past things, like Al's jealousy, by doing the obvious thing-- talking about it. Sounds trite until you hear just how corrosive not talking about something can be.
辛普森夫妇说他们学会了超越那些事，比如艾伦的嫉妒，通过做显而易见的事——谈论它。听起来很陈腐，直到你听到不谈论某件事会有多大的腐蚀性。
The Simpsons told me there was one thing they didn't talk about until they were at least a decade into their marriage, and it didn't come out until after they did some couple's counseling through their church.
辛普森夫妇告诉我，有一件事直到他们结婚至少十年后他们才谈论，而且直到他们通过教会做了一些夫妻咨询后才揭露出来。
And one time-- I don't know, we'd been married 15 years-- she said, I've never told you something. And I said, well, go ahead.
有一次——我不知道，我们结婚15年了——她说，我有一件事从没告诉过你。我说，好吧，说吧。
I'd had an experience of being molested. And it was just something that I was always aware of when I had sex. And once I was able to talk about it, it diminished. It was a gift.
我有过被猥亵的经历。这只是我发生性关系时总是意识到的事。一旦我能谈论它，它就减轻了。这是一个礼物。
It must have made you feel so safe.
那一定让你感到很安全。
It did. I felt safe. That's exactly right. The hardest thing for all couples to talk about is sex. And it's hard to believe, but it is. And the big issues in all marriages that hang it up is your sexual relationship. We're older, so it isn't the issue now that it was when we were young, but it was a big issue, and it is in all marriages.
是的。我感到安全。那完全正确。所有夫妇最难谈论的事情就是性。这很难相信，但事实确实如此。所有婚姻中阻碍进展的大问题就是你们的性关系。我们老了，所以它不再像年轻时那样是个问题了，但在所有婚姻中这确实是一个大问题。
Well, then when you talk about it you think, well, there's a couple of horny people. No, that's not the point. It's called intimacy. Scratch my back, give me a hug, just a hug. And I said, OK. [PANTING] You know. But just a touch. You know, a whack on the fanny in the kitchen or whatever, whatever.
好吧，当你谈论它时，你会想，嗯，那是几个好色的人。不，重点不在这儿。这叫亲密。抓抓我的背，给我个拥抱，只是一个拥抱。我说，好的。 [喘息] 你知道。只是触碰。你知道，在厨房里拍拍屁股之类的，无论什么。
Hearing these very personal details about their marriage, I could almost forget about their very public lives. But then Al and Ann told me about one of their hardest moments. It happened right at the center of a national controversy.
听到关于他们婚姻这些非常私人的细节，我几乎可以忘记他们非常公开的生活。但接着艾伦和安告诉了我他们最艰难的时刻之一。它恰好发生在国家争议的中心。
Tell them about--
告诉他们关于——
Yes. That's when he was in the Clarence Thomas thing.
是的。那就是他在克拉伦斯·托马斯（Clarence Thomas）那件事的时候。
Pissed me off.
激怒了我。
And I said to all the men on that one-- I said, you all came across like a bunch of bullies.
我对那次的所有男人说——我说，你们所有人看起来就像一群欺凌者。
This was back in 1991. If you remember, Clarence Thomas was a nominee for the Supreme Court. A law professor named Anita Hill told the Senate Judiciary Committee that Thomas had sexually harassed her when he was her boss. Al Simpson was a Republican on that committee, and he had some questions about Anita Hill's story and her motives.
那是1991年。如果你还记得，克拉伦斯·托马斯是最高法院的提名人。一位名叫安妮塔·希尔（Anita Hill）的法学教授告诉参议院司法委员会，托马斯在她做他下属时对她进行过性骚扰。艾伦·辛普森是委员会中的共和党人，他对安妮塔·希尔的故事和动机提出了一些质疑。
If what you say this man said to you occurred, why in God's name would you ever speak to a man like that the rest of your life?
如果这个男人对你说的话发生了，为什么你这辈子还会和那样的人说话？
That's a very good question.
那是一个非常好的问题。
While the hearings were happening in DC, Ann was back in Wyoming, caring for her mother who was critically ill.
当听证会在华盛顿发生时，安在怀俄明州，照顾她病危的母亲。
And I was not following it moment by moment. And when I finally did, I just couldn't believe the way Al was operating. And I did tell him, you all sound terrible. You sound like a bunch of male chauvinist pigs.
我并没有时刻关注它。当我最终关注时，我简直不敢相信艾伦的操作方式。我确实告诉他，你们听起来很糟糕。听起来像一群大男子主义的猪。
Al and Ann said they talked every night during those hearings.
艾伦和安说他们在听证会期间每晚都通电话。
And I would say, you know--
我会说，你知道——
She'd say, I don't know what you were doing today, but for God's sake, you looked really nasty.
她说，我不知道你今天在做什么，但看在上帝的份上，你看起来真的很恶心。
You looked like a beast.
你看起来像个野兽。
But don't forget, I'd had a wife-- I never said who a wife-- a mother-- one of whom had been abused.
但别忘了，我曾有过一位妻子——我从没说过是谁的妻子——一位母亲——其中之一曾被虐待过。
There are a lot of ways to justify it.
有很多理由可以为它辩解。
One of whom who'd had much more harassment than Anita Hill. And that's where I lost my marbles. I thought, what is this? I mean, for God's sake, what did he do? Well, nothing. Did he touch you? No. What it it? Well, he wanted to talk about Long Dong Silver, and pubic hair, and Coke cans. Is that it? Yes it is. I wanted you to be aware of his behavior. And so I was a monster. I just was pissed to the core.
其中一个曾遭受过比安妮塔·希尔多得多的骚扰。那是我失去理智的地方。我想，这是什么？我的意思是，看在上帝的份上，他做了什么？好吧，没什么。他碰你了吗？不。那是为了什么？好吧，他想谈论“长棍银”（Long Dong Silver）、阴毛和可乐罐。就是这样吗？是的，就是这样。我只是想让你意识到他的行为。所以我成了个怪物。我只是被气到了骨子里。
Al Simpson got called out, not just by his wife. Editorials across the country blasted him for attacking Anita Hill with rumor and innuendo. Al Simpson lashed back at the press, and Ann knew he was going too far.
艾伦·辛普森不仅被妻子批评了。全国各地的社论都抨击他用谣言和影射攻击安妮塔·希尔。艾伦·辛普森回击了媒体，安知道他走得太远了。
He just kept getting more and more worked up. They had lost their balance. And then, one time he was at home and I said, you know, you have a wonderful reputation the way you've always operated. And it seems to me that you are caught in something, and you just need to shut up.
他只是变得越来越激动。他们失去了平衡。然后，有一次他在家，我说，你知道，你一直以来的操作方式享有极好的声誉。在我看来，你陷入了什么事情中，你只需要闭嘴。
Shut up.
闭嘴。
He said, you've never said that to me before. And I said, well I am now. There's a time to just recognize when you're out of control. And sometimes you have to identify that in the other person.
他说，你以前从没那样对我说话。我说，好吧，我现在说了。有时候要认清你何时失控了。有时候你必须在另一个人身上识别出这一点。
This is still a tender spot for Al Simpson when it comes up. Somethings he's contrite about, other things he re-litigates. And Ann's still disappointed. It's not resolved, it's just passed, stitched into their long relationship together. That's what the Simpsons kept saying to me. You're never going to get rid of conflict, so you have to face it. And you have to do that together.
当这件事被提起时，这仍然是艾伦·辛普森的一个敏感点。有些事他感到忏悔，有些事他重审。安仍然感到失望。这没有解决，只是过去了，缝合进了他们长期的关系中。这就是辛普森夫妇一直对我说的。你永远无法摆脱冲突，所以你必须面对它。你必须一起面对。
That's all it is. You decide to make it work. There are lot's of different ways. We had ways. Other people have different ways. You make a decision.
就是这样。你决定让它行得通。有很多不同的方式。我们有我们的方式。别人有不同的方式。你做一个决定。
That was the big thing I had to do, decide. We didn't have to have all the logistics hammered out, we just had to make the choice to figure it out together. So as crazy as it sounds, Arthur's letter to Al Simpson worked, not because he convinced a retired politician to call me up, but because it reminded me of the kind of man Arthur is-- dogged, and brave, and willing to ask for help when we need it. A good person to spend decades figuring things out with.
那是必须要做的最大的事，决定。我们不必把所有后勤细节都敲定，我们只需要做出选择，一起弄清楚。所以尽管听起来很疯狂，亚瑟给艾伦·辛普森的信奏效了，不是因为他说服了一个退休政治家给我打电话，而是因为它提醒了我亚瑟是哪种人——坚毅、勇敢，并且在我们需要时愿意寻求帮助。一个可以一起共度几十年的好人。
And Al and Ann Simpson, they still keep up with us. They just had Arthur over for dinner when he was back in Wyoming for work. Ann kept asking him when we were going to get married already. She even offered possible venues in town. I think Al thought she was being a little pushy. Because the next day, I was sitting at my desk in New York and my cell phone rang. It was former Senator Alan Simpson, calling again to talk about my love life. He wanted me to know Arthur handled it all just fine.
艾伦和安·辛普森，他们仍然和我们保持联系。当亚瑟回到怀俄明州工作时，他们刚请他吃了顿饭。安一直在问他我们打算什么时候结婚。她甚至提议了镇上可能的场所。我觉得艾伦认为她有点急于求成。因为第二天，我坐在纽约的桌前，手机响了。是前参议员艾伦·辛普森，再次打电话谈论我的私生活。他想让我知道亚瑟处理得很好。
Anna Sale. This story is part of her brand new podcast, Death, Sex, and Money, which comes from WNYC. It just launched this week. Welcome to the world new podcast. The whole idea of this podcast is that Anna's show is going to feature lots of intimate conversations-- like the one you just heard with the Simpsons-- about things that we all deal with but are usually to polite to bring up. It's free to sign up. Get it weekly. Go to iTunes or deathsexmoney.org.
安娜·塞勒。这个故事是她全新播客《死亡、性和金钱》（Death, Sex, and Money）的一部分，来自WNYC。它本周刚刚推出。欢迎来到这个世界，新的播客。这个播客的全部想法是，安娜的节目将呈现许多亲密的对话——就像你刚才听到的与辛普森夫妇的谈话——关于我们所有人都处理但通常太客气而不敢提出的事情。免费注册。每周获取。去iTunes或deathsexmoney.org。
Act Three, horse of a Different Color. So usually when you look for outside help, what you need is an expert. Right? You need a Senator. You need paramedics with parachutes. You need somebody with experience and skills. Though the family of one of our producers, Chana Joffe-Walt, found themselves with a problem. And after going to all the usual places, and experts, and all that, they found themselves saved not by one of them, but by a complete novice. Just a note, because the story gets into the personal lives of children, we have changed some other names. Here's Chana.
第三幕，不同颜色的马。所以通常当你寻找外部帮助时，你需要的是专家。对吧？你需要一位参议员。你需要带降落伞的医护人员。你需要一个有经验和技能的人。尽管我们制片人之一，查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）的家庭发现自己遇到了问题。而在尝试了所有通常的地方和专家之后，他们发现拯救他们的不是其中之一，而是一个完全的新手。顺便提一下，因为故事涉及儿童的私人生活，我们更改了一些名字。这是查娜。
Usually you have no idea how your new baby compares to her peers until you go to the pediatrician and they put her the scale, they show you those charts, and you can see your kid is under weight or tall. It wasn't like that with my sister Maya. My mom and her partner, Ellen, traveled to China to adopt Maya. And they were part of this big group of adoptive parents who were all hanging around the hotel until the paperwork went through, which meant my step-mom, Ellen, had 35 direct comparisons every day, breakfast, lunch, and dinner.
通常你不知道你的新婴儿与同龄人相比如何，直到你去儿科医生那里，他们把她放到秤上，给你看那些图表，你可以看到你的孩子是体重不足还是个子很高。我妹妹玛雅（Maya）的情况并非如此。我妈妈和她的伴侣艾伦（Ellen）去中国收养了玛雅。他们是那群收养父母的一员，大家都在酒店里等待文书处理完毕，这意味着我的继母艾伦每天早餐、午餐和晚餐都有35个直接的比较对象。
There's a picture that was taken the day before we left that hotel. And all the babies are lined up on a couch, and Maya's in the middle, and Maya looks conspicuously different. The other babies are smiling, or some of them are crying, but there's some kind of-- it's hard to articulate what it is about Maya that looks different. But she just seems like she's not there, like she's out of it.
有一张照片是在我们离开那家酒店的前一天拍的。所有的婴儿都排在沙发上，玛雅在中间，玛雅看起来明显不同。其他婴儿在笑，或者有些人正在哭，但有一种——很难清楚表达玛雅看起来有什么不同。但她看起来就像不在这儿，就像她精神恍惚一样。
Maya turned one while they were still in China. A lot of babies learn to walk around that age, around one year old. Maya couldn't sit up. She couldn't grasp things in her hands, and she would only eat out of a bottle. But as soon as she got home, that changed really quickly. Here's my mom, Sara.
他们在中国时玛雅满了一岁。很多婴儿在一岁左右学会走路。玛雅坐不起来。她无法用手抓东西，而且只吃奶瓶。但一旦她回家，情况很快就改变了。这是我妈妈，萨拉（Sara）。
She learned to sit, and then she learned to eat. And she eventually learned to crawl, and she learned to walk, and she started to talk.
她学会了坐，然后学会了吃。最终她学会了爬，学会了走路，开始说话。
And by three and 1/2, Maya was drawing, using scissors and my microphone.
三岁半时，玛雅已经在画画，使用剪刀和我的麦克风。
Uh, uh, uh. It's not working. Say something.
呃，呃，呃。不行了。说点什么。
Hi, Maya. How are you?
你好，玛雅。你好吗？
I'm fine. I want to watch Mary Poppins.
我很好。我想看《欢乐满人间》（Mary Poppins）。
By five years old, there was no question Maya had bonded with both of her moms.
五岁时，毫无疑问玛雅已经和她的两个妈妈建立了亲密关系。
This is my mother, Ellen. She's going to play Twinkle Twinkle on guitar while I sing along.
这是我的母亲，艾伦。她要在吉他上弹奏《一闪一闪小星星》，我来唱歌。
Maya is 20 years younger than me, but when she was little I showed her off like a grandparent does. She was the MVP of my wedding, running around in her dress and her tool belt, sharing her encyclopedic knowledge of dinosaurs with all my friends. She knew a lot about dinosaurs. Maya could sit down with a guitar and freestyle lyrics about how the super continent Pangaea was separated in the time of the dinosaurs.
玛雅比我小20岁，但她小的时候，我像祖父母那样炫耀她。她是我的婚礼上的MVP，穿着裙子和工具腰带跑来跑去，和我所有的朋友分享她关于恐龙的百科全书式的知识。她对恐龙很了解。玛雅可以坐在吉他前，即兴唱出关于盘古大陆（Pangaea）如何在恐龙时代分裂的歌词。
(SINGING) Pangaea separated in the time of the dinosaurs.
（唱歌）盘古大陆在恐龙时代分裂。
And how one of the biggest meat eaters was Gigantonosaurus, who's tooth was as big as a banana.
以及最大的食肉动物之一是巨齿龙（Gigantonosaurus），它的牙齿像香蕉一样大。
(SINGING) --as a banana. That is so big. Mommy, you should be scared of it.
（唱歌）——像香蕉一样。那太大了。妈妈，你应该害怕它。
I should.
我应该。
So you brought her in. Gallant Fox, Omaha, War Admiral.
所以你把她带来了。加兰特·福克斯（Gallant Fox）、奥马哈（Omaha）、战将（War Admiral）。
Around eight years old, the dinosaur obsession switched to horses, and it's been horses ever since then. A lot of girls love horses-- Maya loves race horses. Maya is now 13, and she will walk right up to you with her pad of paper and just begin talking.
大约八岁时，对恐龙的痴迷转向了马，从那时起就一直离不开马。很多女孩喜欢马——玛雅喜欢赛马。玛雅现在13岁了，她会带着她的记事本直接走向你，然后就开始说话。
516, [INAUDIBLE] Painter, Optimizer.
516，[听不清] 画家，优化者。
It's hard to tell if the obsession with horses is more intense or if it's the same as it was with dinosaurs. Only now it strikes people as a weird instead of cute. It strikes people, as it may have struck you, that Maya has autism. For technical reasons, Maya's never been diagnosed as on the autism spectrum, but she does exhibit almost all the characteristics, including sensitivity to touch, lack of eye contact, obsessive and intense interest in one topic, and difficulty with social emotional reciprocity, what many of us call conversation.
很难说对马的痴迷是否更强烈，还是和恐龙时期一样。只是现在人们觉得它怪怪的，而不是可爱。人们觉得——就像你们可能觉得的那样——玛雅有自闭症。由于技术原因，玛雅从未被诊断为自闭症谱系，但她确实表现出几乎所有的特征，包括对触觉敏感、缺乏目光接触、对一个话题有强迫性和强烈的兴趣，以及在社会情感互惠方面有困难，即我们许多人所说的对话。
Man o' War, [INAUDIBLE].
战马（Man o' War），[听不清]。
What is this that you're reading to me?
你读给我听的这是什么？
Race horse names.
赛马的名字。
But just every race horse that you've ever heard of?
但这只是你听说过的每一匹赛马吗？
Well, the first page, Sir Barton to Affirmed, those 11 are the Triple Crown winners in the United States. Street Life to My Adonis, those are the horses--
嗯，第一页，从“巴顿爵士”（Sir Barton）到“肯定”（Affirmed），那11匹是美国的三冠王冠军。从“街头生活”（Street Life）到“我的阿多尼斯”（My Adonis），那些是马——
Maya can tell you every horse that's won the Triple Crown since 1919, their results, their injuries. She tracks the major awards, such as the Eclipse Award which is comprised of more than a dozen categories, which she will recite unprompted over a snack of Doritos.
玛雅可以告诉你自1919年以来赢得三冠王的每一匹马，它们的比赛结果，它们的伤病情况。她追踪重大奖项，例如Eclipse奖，该奖项由十几个类别组成，她会在吃多力多滋零食时即兴背诵出来。
Three-year-old male, three-year-old female, older male. And then there's the categories for people, which I don't find as interesting.
三岁雄性，三岁雌性，年长雄性。然后是针对人的类别，我觉得那些没那么有趣。
You don't find the categories for people interesting?
你觉得针对人的类别不有趣？
No.
不。
Why not?
为什么不？
Because the people aren't horses.
因为人不是马。
People have always been hard for Maya. In preschool, kindergarten, she never really made friends. We figured she just wasn't interested. But as she got older, it became clear it was the other children who weren't interested in her. First grade, second grade, third grade, the only time Maya ever got invited to someone's house was when the entire class was invited.
人们对玛雅来说总是很难相处。在学前班、幼儿园，她从来没真正交到朋友。我们以为她只是不感兴趣。但随着她长大，很明显是其他孩子对她不感兴趣。一年级、二年级、三年级，玛雅唯一一次被邀请去别人家，是因为全班都被邀请了。
In the meantime, Maya amassed a team of therapists who diagnosed her with reactive attachment disorder, RAD. Kids with RAD have often been neglected or abused as babies. They don't emotionally attach to anyone early so they have attachment disorder, which in Maya's case was just one diagnosis to be followed by a series of others that all seemed to take her most obvious character trait and add the word "disorder" to it.
与此同时，玛雅积攒了一支由治疗师组成的团队，他们诊断她患有反应性依恋障碍（RAD）。患有RAD的孩子通常在婴儿期被忽视或虐待。他们早期没能与任何人建立情感依恋，所以他们有依恋障碍，这在玛雅的案例中只是随后一系列诊断中的一个，所有这些诊断似乎都采用了她最明显的性格特征，并加上了“障碍”这个词。
And true to the label, Maya did not attach to other children, which was so painful to watch. Because it wasn't that she didn't care, she just didn't know how to interact. She didn't know how to have a back and forth. She would ask my mom or Ellen to invite someone over, and that someone would come over, and then they just wouldn't come back or return the invitation. Maya didn't get why her friends were always so busy.
正如标签所言，玛雅没有与其他孩子建立依恋关系，这看在眼里非常痛苦。因为并不是她不在乎，她只是不知道如何互动。她不知道如何进行来回的互动。她会请求我妈妈或艾伦邀请某人过来，那个人会来，然后他们就是不再来了，也不回送邀请。玛雅不明白为什么她的朋友总是那么忙。
Well, at school there were kids who would always be playing together as the same group, same people always playing together. And I was never really a part of those groups. I'm more by myself at recess.
嗯，在学校里，有些孩子总是作为同一个群体在一起玩，同样的人总是聚在一起。我从来没真正参与过这些群体。我在休息时间更多是一个人待着。
What do you do at recess?
休息时间你做什么？
Draw, play games that don't involve many people.
画画，玩不需要太多人的游戏。
In fourth grade, in a bout of utter boredom, Maya went and knocked on the neighbor's door. She asked if their boys could play. They were busy. And then Maya sat down on their porch and just started wailing, "No one will play with me."
四年级时，在极度无聊中，玛雅去敲了邻居的门。她问他们的男孩能不能玩。他们很忙。然后玛雅坐在他们的门廊上开始嚎啕大哭：“没人跟我玩。”
And then things got really dark. She stopped asking for play dates all together. She stopped reading. She stopped smiling, and sleeping. And she was on the edge all the time, especially at school. A kid would take her pencil or brush up against her at the bus stop, and Maya would blow up. She had to be physically restrained. She broke a window. She was diagnosed with oppositional defiant disorder. She got hospitalized for a brief period. Here's my step-mom, Ellen.
然后事情变得非常糟糕。她完全停止了请求玩耍。她停止了阅读。她停止了微笑和睡觉。她一直处于崩溃边缘，尤其是在学校。一个孩子拿走了她的铅笔或在公共汽车站擦过她，玛雅就会爆发。她必须被物理束缚。她打碎了一扇窗户。她被诊断为对立违抗性障碍。她短暂住院了一段时间。这是我的继母，艾伦。
How I felt so helpless. And I had no idea what to do. And none of this [BLEEP] is working. None of it's working. And I'm out of ideas. Like, help. What are we going to do with this kid?
我感到多么无助。我不知道该怎么办。而且这些 [粗话] 都不起作用。一点用都没有。我没招了。求救。我们要拿这个孩子怎么办？
In our family, we talk about Maya's life in two sections, BC and AC. Everything I've just told you about, that's all BC, before Charlotte. What happened next is AC, after Charlotte. And this is Charlotte.
在我们家，我们把玛雅的生活分为两个时期，BC和AC。我刚才告诉你的所有这些，那都是BC，Charlotte（夏洛特）之前。接下来发生的是AC，Charlotte之后。这就是Charlotte。
Well, it was the first day of this camp, it was really hot, and we were just waiting for everyone to get there, and we were hanging out. And it was a horse camp, so we were watching these guys throw hay down from a hay loft in the barn. And Maya goes, I did that one time at a place called Hay Down Farm. And we thought that was hilarious for six months.
嗯，那是夏令营的第一天，天气真的很热，我们正在等所有人到齐，我们在闲逛。那是马术夏令营，所以我们看着这些人在谷仓的干草棚里扔干草。玛雅说，我在一个叫“干草农场”（Hay Down Farm）的地方做过一次。我们觉得那很有趣，持续了六个月。
Hay down. Get it? You do get it? Don't over think it. That is the entire joke. Maya had found her audience. Her audience was Charlotte.
干草放下（Hay down）。懂了吗？你真的懂了吗？别想太多。这就是整个笑话。玛雅找到了她的听众。她的听众是Charlotte。
As a parent, you try to construct various environments for your kids so that when you have to cast them off on their own, hopefully the right thing will happen. You baby-proof the cabinet so hopefully the baby won't eat poison. You put the kid in a good school and hope she'll learn math. Ellen put Maya in horse camp, but by this point, by the time Maya was 11 years old, a friend was not even on Ellen's list of things to hope for. They'd given up on that. She just wanted to see her kid smile once or twice a week.
作为父母，你试图为你的孩子构建各种环境，这样当你不得不把他们推向独立时，希望正确的事情会发生。你对柜子做防幼童处理，这样希望婴儿不会吃毒药。你让孩子去好学校，希望她能学会数学。艾伦把玛雅送进了马术夏令营，但到这个时候，到玛雅11岁时，朋友甚至不在艾伦希望的名单上。他们放弃了那点。她只是想每周看到她的孩子笑一两次。
But she dropped Maya off the second day of camp--
但第二天她送玛雅去夏令营——
And I met Charlotte's mom there. And I said, Maya seems to be kind of connecting with Charlotte. And she said, yeah. Charlotte really is feeling a connection with Maya too. And in fact, she said, Mommy, Maya is perfect. And my jaw practically hit the ground with a thud. I just kept saying it to myself in the car all the way home, Maya is perfect. Mommy, Maya is perfect. I was like, this is not possible. But it is. Her mom said it. It must have really happened.
我在那里见到了Charlotte的妈妈。我说，玛雅似乎在和Charlotte建立某种联系。她说，是的。Charlotte确实也对玛雅产生了联系。事实上，她说，妈妈，玛雅是完美的。我的下巴几乎重重地掉到了地上。我一直在车里回家的路上对自己重复这句话，玛雅是完美的。妈妈，玛雅是完美的。我心想，这不可能。但这确实发生了。她妈妈说的。它一定真的发生了。
I asked Charlotte recently why Maya was perfect. She told me it was pretty simple, actually.
我最近问Charlotte为什么玛雅是完美的。她告诉我，这其实很简单。
She was the only girl my age at camp.
她是营地里唯一和我同龄的女孩。
Did you like her?
你喜欢她吗？
Yeah. It was pretty clear from the beginning that we had a lot of common interests.
是的。从一开始就很明显，我们有很多共同兴趣。
Like what?
比如什么？
Horses. Um, yeah.
马。嗯，是的。
Perfect. Charlotte invited Maya over for a play date that Thursday, just like that. No big deal, just, hey, you want to come over? And she did. Maya went over. And it went fine. There was another play date, and then another, and another. And Charlotte and Maya would sit on the floor together with their model horses. Mostly they did their own thing. They weren't talking or laughing a lot, but we all thought, wow, this is working. Maya has a companion.
完美。Charlotte邀请玛雅周四去玩耍，就像那样。没什么大不了的，只是，嘿，你想过来玩吗？她去了。玛雅过去了。一切都很顺利。又进行了一次玩耍，然后又一次，又一次。Charlotte和玛雅会坐在地板上一起玩她们的模型马。大多数时候她们各玩各的。她们没有聊很多或笑很多，但我们都心想，哇，这行得通。玛雅有了一个伙伴。
And then a couple months in, they invited Charlotte on an overnight to DC. And afterwards they got a hotel, and Ellen could hear the kids in the other room telling jokes.
几个月后，她们邀请Charlotte去华盛顿过夜。之后她们开了一间房，艾伦能听到孩子们在隔壁房间讲笑话。
And they just cracked up, and Maya lost it, and she just started laughing, and laughing, and laughing. And Charlotte making fart jokes, and Maya just exploding in laughter. And I was lying there in the other room thinking, this is a miracle. I can't believe this is happening. She's giggling and talking and whispering at a sleepover like a regular kid.
她们只是爆笑，玛雅彻底放开了，她开始笑，笑，笑个不停。Charlotte讲屁笑话，玛雅只是爆发出大笑。我躺在隔壁房间心想，这是一个奇迹。我不敢相信这正在发生。她像个正常的孩子一样在过夜聚会上咯咯笑、说话、耳语。
What would you have imagined Maya would do in that situation?
你会想象玛雅在这种情况下会做什么？
I would have imagined her saying, hey, go to sleep. It's night time. The light is off. I am tired. But that night, Maya discovered what a sleepover could be.
我会想象她说，嘿，去睡觉。现在是晚上了。灯关了。我累了。但那天晚上，玛雅发现了过夜聚会可以是怎样的。
My mom had a moment like this too, where she realized that AC was a wildly different era than BC. She was watching Maya with Charlotte, and at first she couldn't figure out what was going on with Maya. She looked weird. And then my mom realized, oh, that's happiness.
我妈妈也有过这样的时刻，她意识到AC是一个与BC截然不同的时代。她在观察玛雅和Charlotte，起初她想不出玛雅怎么了。她看起来怪怪的。然后我妈妈意识到，哦，那是快乐。
It's just hard to describe how thrilled she was. I felt like Maya would jump out of her skin. AC is just that kind of engagement with somebody else, and engagement in the world. I had hardly seen it in years at all.
很难描述她有多激动。我觉得玛雅会跳出她的皮肤。AC就是那种与他人互动，以及参与到世界中的状态。我几乎已经好几年没见到它了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Maya just turned 13 a couple weeks ago. The only thing she wanted for her birthday was a sleepover with Charlotte. So Charlotte came over and the two of them sat on the floor with their model horses for hours.
玛雅几周前刚满13岁。她生日那天唯一想要的就是和Charlotte过夜。所以Charlotte过来了，她们俩在地板上拿着模型马坐了几个小时。
What's your name?
你叫什么名字？
Sonia.
索尼娅（Sonia）。
What's your name?
你叫什么名字？
I'm Secretariat.
我是“秘书长”（Secretariat）。
Charlotte loves to play Hailey, a young rider who's whiny and thinks she knows everything. Maya likes to play, well, Maya, someone who does know everything and can set Hailey in her place.
Charlotte喜欢扮演海莉（Hailey），一个年轻、爱抱怨且认为自己什么都知道的骑手。玛雅喜欢扮演，好吧，玛雅，一个确实什么都知道且能让海莉闭嘴的人。
I've done everything after.
我做过之后的一切。
You haven't Have you raced in the Kentucky Derby?
你没有。你参加过肯塔基德比大赛（Kentucky Derby）吗？
Probably. I don't know. I don't remember. I would've been really little.
可能吧。我不知道。我不记得了。我那时候一定非常小。
I take that as a no. You have not raced in the Kentucky Derby, because really little people do not-- really young people do not race in the Kentucky Derby.
我把它当成否定的回答。你没有参加过肯塔基德比，因为真的小孩子不会——真的年轻人不会参加肯塔基德比。
How do you know I'm not 80-hundred years old and I'm just short because I'm a jockey?
你怎么知道我不是8000岁，我只是因为我是骑师才这么矮？
Oh my gosh. 80-hundred years old. No one's lived to be that old.
哦，天哪。8000岁。没人活到那么大年纪。
How do you know? Have you died yet?
你怎么知道？你死了吗？
No.
没有。
Well then how do you know you're not going to live to 80-hundred years old? Year's old.
那你怎么知道你不会活到8000岁？
Because people just don't live that long.
因为人就是活不了那么久。
That right there, that is a genuine back and forth interaction. Maya is not lecturing, she's not ignoring Charlotte. She's amused. She is feeling amusement. And she's responding directly to what Charlotte is saying.
就是那一点，那是一个真实的互动交流。玛雅没有在说教，她没有忽视Charlotte。她感到很有趣。她感到了快乐。她正在直接回应Charlotte说的话。
Maya and Charlotte have been friends for almost two years now. We'll be two years into AC this summer. And here are the basic facts of AC. Maya no longer regularly gets in trouble at school. She now does her homework and washes her hair without a struggle. She has not had one violent incident AC. She makes eye contact sometimes. She asks, how are you, sometimes. She does chores. That felt impossible BC. All of it seemed impossible BC.
玛雅和Charlotte做朋友快两年了。今年夏天我们将进入AC的第二年。这是AC的基本事实。玛雅不再在学校定期闯祸。她现在做家庭作业，洗头时也不再挣扎。她在AC期间没有发生过一次暴力事件。她有时会进行目光接触。她有时会问，你好吗。她做家务。在BC时期这感觉是不可能的。BC时这一切看起来都不可能。
The other day I went to pick up Maya from school, and her bus driver got out of the bus to introduce himself to me and tell me, Maya, she's really worked on herself this year. She's doing great. Her horseback riding instructor pulled my mom aside the other day to say, Maya has been making eye contact with me. I've never seen that before. It feels like when people see a really beautiful piece of art and they can't wait to talk to someone about it. Just to say, did you see that? Awesome, right?
前几天我去学校接玛雅，她的校车司机下车向我自我介绍，告诉我，玛雅，她今年真的很努力改变自己。她做得很好。她的骑马教练前几天把我拉到一边说，玛雅一直在和我进行目光接触。我以前从没见过那样。这感觉就像人们看到一件非常美丽的艺术品，迫不及待地想和某人谈论它。只是想说，你看到了吗？太棒了，对吧？
And Charlotte, I can't imagine a kid better suited to being Maya's friend than Charlotte. Just listen to the way she talks, and try to remember, this kid is 13 years old.
还有Charlotte，我无法想象一个比Charlotte更适合做玛雅朋友的孩子。只要听听她说话的方式，试着记住，这个孩子才13岁。
How would you describe Maya?
你会怎么描述玛雅？
She's extremely obsessed with race horses.
她极度痴迷于赛马。
What's that been like for you?
这对你来说意味着什么？
Well, I've learned a lot of new stuff from her actually, because half the time it's all she'll talk about. But it's been really interesting because it's a whole new part of the horse world that I wasn't really familiar with until I met her. You know, all the Triple Crown winners in order.
嗯，其实我从她那儿学到了很多新东西，因为有一半时间她只会聊这些。但这真的很有趣，因为这是马术界的一个全新领域，在我遇到她之前我并不太熟悉。你知道，所有的三冠王冠军顺序。
What else do you know about her?
关于她你还知道什么？
She's really smart. But sometimes she's a bit lacking in social graces. Just a little bit. Sometimes it makes her really funny.
她真的很聪明。但有时她有点缺乏社交礼仪。就一点点。有时这让她真的很滑稽。
Charlotte's noticed that if she talks about something she's interested in that's not horses, like Star Trek, or Harry Potter, it used to be that Maya just wouldn't respond. She didn't know what to say. But lately, Charlotte says, Maya tries to be interested in whatever she's talking about.
Charlotte注意到，如果她谈论一些她感兴趣的不是马的事情，比如《星际迷航》或《哈利·波特》，过去玛雅只是不会回应。她不知道该说什么。但最近，Charlotte说，玛雅会试着对她谈论的任何事情表现出兴趣。
And sometimes she'll even respond to it by connecting it to horses, which I think is a neat thing to be able to do. I just think it's really cool when people connect everyday things to things that are really their passion.
有时她甚至会通过将其与马联系起来来回应，我认为这是一种巧妙的能力。我觉得当人们把日常琐事与真正让他们充满激情的事情联系起来时，真的很酷。
Yeah. That's really smart.
是的。那真的很聪明。
It can be a great way to interact with the world.
这可以是与世界互动的一种很好的方式。
When I ask her how she deals with it when Maya has tantrums, Charlotte says, sometimes I wait it out, or sometimes integrating humor can be helpful. See what I mean? That's a special kid. And Maya can see that.
当我问她当玛雅闹脾气时她是如何处理的，Charlotte说，有时我等它过去，或者有时加入幽默会有帮助。看到我的意思了吗？那是一个特别的孩子。玛雅能看出来。
This is a really important friendship. And I've been learning how to be a better friend in order to keep the friendship.
这是一个非常重要的友谊。我一直在学习如何成为一个更好的朋友，以维持这段友谊。
Like what kinds of things are you learning?
比如你正在学习什么样的东西？
Be more flexible. Not just talk about what you want to talk about all the time. Do other stuff that your friend wants. The morning after Maya's birthday sleepover, I found her sitting outside the bedroom door at 6:00 in the morning waiting for Charlotte to wake up. She wasn't allowed to wake her up until 8:00, so Maya was just sitting there.
更灵活。不要总是只谈论你想谈论的事情。做一些你的朋友想做的其他事。玛雅生日过夜后的第二天早晨，我发现她早上6点坐在卧室门外等着Charlotte醒来。她不被允许在8点前吵醒她，所以玛雅只是坐在那里。
I don't think I'd completely gotten this until I saw Maya waiting-- Maya loves Charlotte. She loves her. She feels the feelings that come when you're a girl and you have a friend who makes you laugh, and thinks about you when you're apart, and gets you. It's not a romantic love, but if you've had this, you know it feels just as important.
直到我看到玛雅在等待时，我才完全明白这一点——玛雅爱Charlotte。她爱她。她感受到了当你是一个女孩，有一个让你发笑的朋友，在你不在时会想到你，并懂你的那种感觉。那不是浪漫的爱，但如果你曾经有过这样的经历，你知道它感觉一样重要。
Maya is getting to experience the joy of being 13 and having a best friend. And that is why she's willing to work so hard. It's why she's trying to learn how to read facial expressions, and social cues, to control waves of anger and frustration, to sit still when all you want is to wake someone up. You have to really want something to work that hard for it.
玛雅正在体验13岁并拥有一个最好的朋友的快乐。这就是为什么她愿意如此努力。这就是为什么她正在尝试学习如何阅读面部表情、社交线索，控制愤怒和沮丧的浪潮，当你想吵醒某人时坐着不动。你必须真的很想要某样东西才会如此努力。
Charlotte's going to high school next year and she's just growing up faster than Maya is. She could move on, maybe soon, something we talk about all the time and try not to think about. We know BC, and we know AC, but we don't know what comes after. Maya needed the friendship to learn how to be a friend, but maybe, hopefully, now she knows. And with or without Charlotte, she'll be OK.
Charlotte明年要上高中了，她比玛雅长得快。她可能会搬走，也许很快，这是我们一直谈论但尽量不去想的事情。我们知道BC，我们知道AC，但我们不知道AC之后会是什么。玛雅需要这段友谊来学习如何成为一个朋友，但也许，希望如此，现在她知道了。无论有没有Charlotte，她都会没事的。
Chana Joffe-Walt is one of the producers of our show.
查娜·乔夫-沃尔特是我们节目的制片人之一。
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Alison Davis. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon is our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our administrative assistant Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Research help from Julie Beer and Michelle Harris. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
我们今天的节目由罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、斯蒂芬妮·傅（Stephanie Foo）、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、萨拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）参与。我们的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。艾莉森·戴维斯（Alison Davis）提供制作帮助。塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的行政助理。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨（Adrianne Mathiowetz）负责我们的网站。研究协助来自朱莉·贝尔（Julie Beer）和米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）和罗伯·格迪斯（Rob Geddis）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS] Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia. You know he always reminds me, when our program is on the air, he sits at the radio station's master control console, his finger poised above the controls, and at any moment, any moment at all I do anything he doesn't like.
[致谢] 我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《这个美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道他总是提醒我，当我们的节目在播出时，他坐在电台的广播控制台，手指悬在控制键上方，随时，任何时刻，我做了任何他不喜欢的行为。
Ba-dupe, press this little button, and then that's it. Game over.
嘟的一声，按下这个小按钮，然后就是这样。游戏结束。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《这个美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。